et pour parler de la campagne
présidentielle nous sommes avec françois
durpaire historien spécialiste des états
unis françois durpaire bonsoir merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors après son hospitalisation et après
avoir testé positif aux convives donald
trump entame donc son marathon avec
trois meetings en trois jours est-ce
qu'il peut encore rattraper son retard
dans les sondages
s'il n'y avait pas le précédent de 2016
je vous dirai non
pourquoi parce que l'écart entre les
deux candidats et un écart qui n'a
jamais été rencontrés depuis 1996 c'est
ainsi qu'à un écart qui en est en
moyenne de sondages nationaux et de 9,7
je vous dis bien moyenne de son gaz pas
un seul sondage et sur les états clés là
aussi on a une avance de joe madden très
importante
alors pourquoi je vous dirai pas c'est
jouer parce que vous souvenez de 2016
on pensait qu'il a acquis une tonnelle
et l'emporté néanmoins elle a perdu mais
simplement il faut quand même se
remettre dans ce qui s'est passé en 2016
hillary clinton était une candidate
polarisantes le parti démocrate était
divisé et on a appris à dix jours de
l'élection qu'il y avait une enquête
contre elle du fbi y aille
et malgré ça elle a gagné le vote
populaire à 3 millions de voix et il a
fallu les conjugaisons de 70 mille
électeurs en trois étapes pour que
donald trump passe dans un trou de
souris
donc je ne vous dis pas qu'en 2020 il va
perdre mais je vous dis que le trou de
souris il sera encore plus petit parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas cinq points
d'avance comme il ya quatre ans que
hillary clinton que les démocrates
avaient c'est aujourd'hui 9.7 fait de
refuser de participer au deuxième débat
face à joe biden est ce que finalement
c'est pas un pari risqué pour donald
trump
alors c'est très risqué pour donald
trump parce que vous le savez il avait
même demandé plus de débat lui il lui
faut plus d'événements de campagne vous
savez on dit en octobre il ya la
surprise d'octobre bibi faudrait
quasiment une surprise par jour pour que
quelque chose se passe de positif et ne
pas avoir de débat
et pour lui en avoir encore un quand
même hein c'est pour lui tout jouer sur
un seul débat
en revanche les sénateurs républicains
ils sont plutôt contents parce que le
débat s'est plutôt mal passé pour donald
trump et pour les républicains
parce que finalement depuis on a de son
âge très mauvais au sénat les
républicains perdre le sénat ou de
remplir si on devait voter
il y aurait 40 9 républicains et 51
démocrate ou c'est là ça serait la passe
de trois pour les démocrates et donc
certains sénateurs républicains se
disent bon quitte à perdre la maison
blanche on perd la maison blanche mais
au moins sauvegardons le sénat alors le
taux de chômage s'élève à 7 9 %
aujourd'hui notamment à cause du coût
vide c'est le taux le plus haut à la
veille d'une élection depuis la fin de
la seconde guerre mondiale est ce que
c'est un cataclysme au fond pour le
président qui avait tout misé sur son
bilan économique
oui au regard de l'histoire parce que il
n'ya que trois présidents qui n'ont pas
été ré depuis 1912
la règle c'est la réélection 1 les
américains se disent en gros ou quatre
ans y at il vraiment une raison de
remplacer le président et la plupart
dans la plupart des cas elles répondent
non la seule fois où ils répondent oui
c'est quand il ya récession économique
donc on a ouvert qui n'a pas été réélu
carter qui n'apparaît été réélu et bush
bush père qui n'a pas été réélu donc
être élu à plus de 7% de chômage si de
la trempe le fait ce sera le premier à
le faire en histoire c'est évidemment
très embarrassant présent btampon lui
alors j'ai l'impression de donner que
des arguments négatifs pour donald trump
il ya encore peut-être des inconnus à
cette élection
la première inconnue c'est la question
des sondages
est ce qu'il n'ya pas dans les sondages
des erreurs en particulier en parle
beaucoup des électeurs cachée de ceux
qui n'osent pas dire qu'ils voteront
trinquent
notamment chez les minorités et des
premiers électeurs qui avait fait aussi
le succès donald rentes sa capacité à
mobiliser des gens à politique
la deuxième chose c'est
la manière dont le co vide va impacter
cette élection en termes de mobilisation
et en terme est bien de personnes qui
vont se déplacer notamment donald trump
a dit à quelques heures je veux
connaître le résultat de l'élection le 3
novembre
or s'il connaît le lections le 3
novembre il va perdre donc lui il a
plutôt intérêt à ce que ça dure et
est-ce qu'on recompte des votes dans sa
pensée tap que ça voudra dire que c'est
serré un comme ça c'est vraiment là
l'atout deuxième chose et puis la
troisième chose c'est c'est donald trump
quel va être son attitude si c'est serré
et ce qui va accepter éventuellement sa
défaite ça c'est pas du tout sûr donc
qu'il ya quand même des inconnus dans
cette élection qui font qu'on va suivre
ça de près qu'on ne peut pas dire vingt
jours avant
joe biden a gagné et puis le sénat a un
qui a entamé hier la confirmation à
l'atteinte de la juge amy connaît
barrette est ce que cela pourrait
influer coûter cher ou pas dans les
urnes à donald trump
alors là la conséquence de la domination
de la juge barrette
ça peut avoir une conséquence dans les
deux camps stimuler le camp républicain
et les conservateurs qui vont se dire on
a assis à la cour suprême une génération
de décisions conservatrices et le très
bon bilan de donald trump chez les
conservateurs c'est qu'il a nommé plus
de 200 juges fédéraux
donc les trois juges à la cour suprême
plus de cent jugent dans les cours
fédérales
c'est très important pour lui la
deuxième chose c'est plutôt le long
terme évidemment les démocrates qu'ils
peuvent aussi se retourner en se disant
ça peut les stimuler aussi de se dire on
va faire la passe de trois chambre des
représentants sénat et maison blanche
contre la cour suprême
mais ce qui compte c'est le long terme
le long terme ça voudrait dire que si
joe biden est élu il va y avoir une
cohabitation difficile entre l'exécutif
et non pas le législatif
mais le judiciaire et on peut penser
notamment en matière de green new deal
de son grand projet écologique
que la cour suprême et c'est un peu
technique dont je veux pas revenir
aujourd'hui là dessus et pourquoi la
cour suprême pourrait bloquer mais on
peut penser que les six juges contre
trois pourrait durablement bloquée le
gouvernement fédéral au niveau de son
exécutif est embarrassé le président je
vous parle pas évidemment de la question
du droit à l'avortement qui pourrait
aussi être mise en cause
pas en l'abolissant de manière
centralisée à la française mais est un
par état en laissant faire et les états
qui voudraient légiférer de manière
beaucoup plus restrictif sur ce droit à
l'avortement
alors il se dit également que l'une des
seules solutions pour donald trump de
recoller dans les sondages et bien c'est
de mobiliser massivement les américains
blancs non diplômés est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette analyse
c'est la stratégie de date
la stratégie de donald trump vous avez
vu c'est non pas d'élargir forcément sur
les indécis vous avez d'ailleurs entendu
la différence peut-être de discours
entre mike pence le vice président dans
son discours dans son débat contre
kamala harris il avait il avait un
discours à la fois très conservateur
mais qui visait à séduire des indécis
conservateur et donald trump
on le sent vraiment mobilisés sur je
vais aller chercher effectivement cet
électorat blanc qui ne veut pas qui est
extrêmement déçue la politique et c'est
peut-être la prouesse de donna train il
a été un candidat antisystème et quatre
ans après il reste un président qui
apparaît comme anti système
ça c'est ça c'est sa proue est est ce
que ça va suffire pour gagner les
élections
lui il vise vraiment cette mobilisation
très fort de cet électorat là est ce que
ça peut suffire ça il ya que le 3 9 ans
qui pourra nous le dire certains disent
que non parce que ça il aurait fallu
unifié plus largement
lui pense qu'il y a un réservoir de voix
considérable et vous savez des chefs
d'état la plupart du temps quand ils
gagnent élections la première fois ils
cherchent à regagner la même manière
c'est assez rare quand il se remet en
cause en se disant ma campagne de
réélection ne doit pas ressembler à
campagne d'élection c'est peut-être
parfois une erreur et vous avez vu le
slogan de donna train keep america great
games ça ressemble très fortement à
mettre l'amérique a great games et
pourquoi ça peut ne pas marcher parce
qu'il ya des américains qui peuvent se
dire on n'a pas réussi mais cameron kate
gagne alcôves u19 118 américain 118
évidemment son bord 7 millions et 700
villes américains qui sont touchés par
la maladie alors c'est pas certains
disent évidemment c'est pas donald trump
mais d'autres américains désirent aussi
une responsabilité dans sa gestion
ducobu de 19
donc il ya quelques mois les américains
ont répondu à la question il n'y a pas
forcément de raison de changer président
mais le 3 novembre
et vu le la question économique et la
question sanitaire aux états unis il ya
quand même beaucoup d'américains qui
certainement choisiront de changer on
peut pas en être certain mais cette
élection reste indécise mais on ne peut
pas ne plus dire que donald trump soit
le favori à sa réélection
merci beaucoup françois durpaire je
rappelle que vous êtes historien
spécialiste des états unis